[Musique]
vous avez ici les mots isolde qui est la
partie centrale de l'irm de recherche
isole qui va être installé à neurospin
donc c'est un projet qui a été lancé il
ya une quinzaine d'années pour délivrer
sur le site de neurospin léman le plus
puissant au monde
donc après la mise en fonctionnement de
cette irm unique nous allons pouvoir
explorer le cerveau avec une résolution
spatiale très impressionnant puisque par
rapport aux irm actuelles qui permettent
de voir le cerveau avec une résolution
de l'ordre d'un grain de riz nous allons
pouvoir descendre à l'échelle de
quelques cheveux d'épaisseur donc cela
va nous permettre de mieux comprendre
tous les mécanismes de fonctionnement du
cerveau donc aussi bien le cerveau sain
donc en particulier à neurospin ya déjà
beaucoup d'étude sur le vieillissement
du cerveau donc ça mais également bien
sûr de nous intéresser au développement
des pathologies à leurs différents
mécanismes
nous allons également travailler côté
plus aux neurosciences à l'exploration
des fonctions cognitives avec une
également une meilleure résolution
spatiale donc avec cet élément nouveau à
londres compléter le panel des irm déjà
disponibles et franchir un pas important
donc de faire une meilleure résolution
spatiale pour pousser dans toutes ses
recherches vers une exploration apporte
plus fine du cerveau de son
fonctionnement et des pathologies
associées
la totalité du projet ses 15 ans avec en
gros une première phase de 6 7 ans de
r&d pour développer tous les concepts
ensuite une recherche une partie
recherche de financement est ensuite un
peu plus de six ans pour la fabrication
complète de cet objet unique
[Musique]
dont clément a été livré c'est une étape
importante dans le projet mais c'est
loin d'être la fin l'on va transférer
dans quelques jours les moulins terreur
de l'arche mais il va falloir encore
près d'un an pour mettre tout en place
montez le champ magnétique à 11,7 tesla
et ensuite il faudra plus d'un an pour
transformer cet aimant on a un imageur
complet c'est-à-dire un système capable
de faire des images très précises du
cerveau
[Musique]